>> Laura: THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSES JUBILANT OVER ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE FRAMEWORK CALLING
IT HISTORIC.
SO WHY THE 17 REPUBLICANS WHO
VOTED TO ADVANCE THE BILL
THROWING BIDEN A LIFELINE?
HERE NOW IT'S ONE OF THOSE 17
REPUBLICANS,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THIS IS A TRILLION DOLLAR BILL
AT A TIME WE ARE FACING MASSIVE
INFLATION, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
YOU GUYS HAVE MADE A TERRIBLE
DEAL, THAT REPUBLICANS ARE BIG
LOSERS AND DEMOCRATS ARE THE BIG
WINNERS SO WHY IS HE WRONG?
>> I THINK HE'S WRONG BECAUSE HE
HAD A BILL FOR $1.7 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING WHICH I
SUPPORTED, WE COULD NEVER GET IT
DONE.
1.2 TRILLION FOR ROADS, BRIDGES
AND PORTS AND IF YOU DON'T THINK
WE HAVE A ROAD, BRIDGE AND PORT
PROBLEM YOU ARE NOT LOOKING AT
AMERICA THE WAY IT IS.
THE $3.5 TRILLION BILL THEY WANT
TO FOLLOW UP WITH IS SOCIALISM
BUT COUNT ME IN FOR ROADS,
BRIDGES AND PORTS PAID FOR.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M FOR AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M AGAINST
AND --
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THIS IS
THE SAME ECONOMY AS THERE WAS
ONE PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE?
THAT INFLATIONARY PRESSURE THAT
WE ARE SEEING TODAY HAVE NO
EFFECT ON THE SPENDING AND THAT
THIS IS NOT A GLIDE PATH TO
MAKE --
>> SURE.
>> Laura: $3 TRILLION SPENDING
IS POSSIBLE, HUGE WIN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE, THEY ARE THRILLED.
>> I REALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
AT ALL.
WE ARE PUTTING MONEY ASIDE FOR
AN EIGHT YEAR ROAD, BRIDGE, PORT
PLAN TO UPGRADE, WHAT I JUST
SAID.
THAT CREATES INFLATION AS A
$3.5 TRILLION BILL, WITH TAX
INCREASES.
WE WILL SEE.
ME AND YOU DIFFER ON THIS.
I THINK AMERICA NEEDS
INFRASTRUCTURE, I AM FOR IT.
I THINK AMERICA DOESN'T NEED
SOCIALISM, I'M AGAINST IT --
>> Laura: BUT SENATOR, WHY
DIDN'T YOU DO, NANCY PELOSI
PLAYED HARDBALL AND YOU ROLLED
OVER.
WHY DIDN'T YOU SAY WE WILL VOTE
ON INFRASTRUCTURE ONCE YOU SHOW
YOUR HAND ON THE $3.5 TRILLION?
WHY ARE WE GIVING THE LEVERAGED
AT THE DEMOCRATS ON THE PROCESS?
PELOSI IS LIKE WE ARE NOT DOING
THAT, WE ARE DOING IT THE OTHER
WAY AND YOU GUYS ARE LIKE, OKAY,
INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST.
>> I THINK YOU NAILED SOMETHING.
FOLLOW THIS, IT'S GOING TO PASS
THE SENATE WITH DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT.
$3.5 TRILLION BILL WON'T GET ANY
WHAT DOES NANCY PELOSI DO?
DOES SHE HOLD BIPARTISAN BILL
HOSTAGE, DOES SHE GET THE
$3.5 TRILLION SOCIALIST WISH
LIST?
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT, NANCY.
SHE'S GOING TO MERGE THE TWO
BILLS AND I THINK A COLLAPSE IN
THE HOUSE AND IT WOULD BE A
SHAME IF WE CAN'T DO SOMETHING
GOOD FOR AMERICA BECAUSE SHE
WANTS $3.5 TRILLION TO SOCIALIZE
THE COUNTRY.
WE WILL SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT
IN THE HOUSE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK THE ORDER
OF THESE BILLS WAS CORRECT?
DOING THE INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST
AND THEN LETTING THEM TACKLE THE
$3.5 TRILLION, SHE SAID THAT'S
NOT GOING TO FLY?
OKAY.
>> BUT IN THE SENATE, I THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO BE LESS LIKELY
TO DO A $3.5 TRILLION BILL IF WE
CAN DO A BIPARTISAN BILL WITH A
TRILLION DOLLARS DEDICATED TO
REAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE WILL SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT.
I THINK NANCY PELOSI IS MAKING A
BIG MISTAKE.
SHE'S GOING TO INSIST THE
SOCIALIST BILL PASSES FIRST.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
AND SHE'S GOING TO THROW THE
BIPARTISAN BILL ALL OVER AND
HOLD THEM HOSTAGE AND HOPE THAT
McCARTHY WILL SAY, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO PLAY THAT GAME.
>> Laura: SENATOR, WE HOPE IT
WORK